-Why is the sun so hot?
-Yellow.
-What are...
[ Laughter ]
What are -- what are birds
made out of?
-Plastic.
-How old is Jon Hamm?
-59.
-What was Elvis´s first word?
-Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
-Who stole the eggs?
-Larry and his --
and his brother.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
-Here´s how it works.
We´re gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
-One, two, three, Think Fast!
-Thank you. Yeah, and...
[ Laughter ]
-No, I love it. I love it.
-That´s it.
That was the --
that was the title sequence.
Very good.
One person asks the questions.
The other person has to
answer each question
as soon as it´s asked,
and I mean immediately.
It doesn´t matter
if the answer is right or wrong.
It just has to be the very first
thing that pops into your head.
Will, since you´re the guest,
I´ll read your questions first.
Are you ready?
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
[ Dramatic music playing,
clock ticking ]
Why is the sun so hot?
-Yellow.
-What are...
[ Laughter ]
What are -- what are birds
made out of?
-Plastic.
-How old is Jon Hamm?
-59.
-What was Elvis´s first word?
-Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
-Who stole the eggs?
-Larry and his --
and his brother.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Larry and his brother.
-Larry and his brother
stole the eggs.
Yellow.
-Okay.
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
Now, yeah, you´ll ask questions
and I´ll answer.
-You´re ready, Jimmy?
-Yeah, that was great.
-Okay.
[ Dramatic music playing,
clock ticking ]
What can I buy for a dollar?
-A-A-A sandwich.
-Where are the children hiding?
-In the basement.
[ Laughs ]
-What are sports?
-Things.
-How heavy is the duck?
-12 pounds.
-Tell me a secret.
-Shampoo.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That...
That is a --
That´s a juicy secret.
-Juicy secret.
-That is a juicy secret.
-Here we go.
All right.
[ Clears throat ]
Lights.
Which rabbit is the best?
-Joe.
-How big is the big man?
-Uh, he´s -- he´s bigger.
He´s bigger
than you think he is,
but he´s smaller than a jockey.
-Why were you late
for my wedding?
-Because my dad said,
"Knock it off."
[ Laughter ]
-Name the best place.
-Oh, Alaska.
-What are the names
of the two firemen?
-There´s, uh, Captain Ron.
-[ Laughing ] Captain Ron?
-Yes.
-Yes, and?
-Cecil.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right,
this is the final round.
So here´s what we do.
So I have this, you have that.
In this final round,
we´ll both pick up a card
with the same set of questions.
I´ll ask, you answer.
Then you ask the question.
-And we´ll just back and forth.
-Back and forth, just ping-pong.
Yeah, ready?
-Okay.
-Who drank all the coffee?
-My mom did. She was thirsty.
Where did the money go?
-It´s under the mattress.
What is the name
of your first kiss?
-Uh, mm, ah, yeah.
What would have been
a better name for The Beatles?
-The Skreatles.
What is a jazz boy?
-He´s the guy
who carries the saxophone.
How many people
are there in Canada?
-Three.
What are you?
-I´m me.
What´s a cool greeting?
-Hola!
Why are you so great?
-Because it´s in the genes.
Sing me a song.
-♫ Orlando ♫
[ Dinging ]
Orlando.
-♫ Orlando ♫
-That was Think Fast.
That was Will Ferrell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Don´t Stop Believin´"
playing ]
♫♫
♫ Just a small-town girl ♫
-Where does she live?
-♫ Living in a lonely world ♫
-Does she stay there,
or was she traveling?
-♫ She took the midnight train
going anywhere ♫
-Thank you!
So only a small-town girl,
right?
-♫ Just a city boy ♫
-Oh, there´s more people.
Where´s he from?
-♫ Born and raised
in South Detroit ♫
-I´ve never been there.
I heard it´s nice.
-♫ He took the midnight train
going anywhere ♫
-So they both
took the same train
and went to the same place.
Gotcha!
-♫ A singer in a smoky room ♫
-What is the room smell like?
-♫ The smell of wine
and cheap perfume ♫
-Those things smell bad.
-♫ For a smile
they can share the night ♫
-Okay.
-♫ It goes on and on ♫
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
-♫ And on and on ♫
-Wow, that´s real long.
-♫ Strangers ♫
-What are the strangers doing?
-♫ Waiting ♫
-Where?
♫ Up and down the boulevard ♫
-Yeah, but what are
their shadows doing?
-♫ Shadows searching
in the night ♫
-Is that the end of the song?
-♫ Streetlights ♫
-Oh, there´s more song!
-♫ People ♫
-What are the people´s
life goals?
-♫ Living just to find emotion ♫
-Oh, neat.
-♫ Hiding ♫
-Where and when?
-♫ Somewhere in the niiiight ♫
-Thank you!
Hey, are you having fun?
This is fun!
Ahhhh!
My brother´s name is Gabriel.
He lives in Taco Nano.
-♫ Working hard
just to get my fill ♫
-Do at least some people
want a thrill?
-♫ Everybody wants a thrill ♫
-That´s what I thought.
Just double checking.
-♫ Just to roll the dice
just one more time ♫
-Does everyone win?
-♫ Some will win ♫
-Do some people lose?
-♫ Some will lose ♫
-Are some people
born to sing the blues?
-♫ Some are born
to sing the blues ♫
-Called it.
-♫ Oh, the movie never ends ♫
-Wait! What movie?
-♫ It goes on and on and on ♫
-Long movie alert!
-♫ And on ♫
♫ Strangers ♫
-Wait. The strangers are back?
-♫ Waiting ♫
-Where are they waiting now?
-♫ Up and down the boulevard ♫
-Are there still shadows?
-♫ Shadows searching
in the night ♫
-Hey! you know what I miss?
The streetlights.
-♫ Streetlights ♫
-Yes! They´re back!
-♫ People ♫
-No!
Go back to the streetlights.
-♫ Living just to find emotion ♫
-Who gives a crap?
More streetlights!
-♫ Hiding ♫
♫ Somewhere in the niiight ♫
-Fine. I guess I´m over
the streetlights.
-♫ Don´t stop ♫
-Don´t stop what?
- Believin´ ♫
-Okay, I won´t.
-♫ Hold on to that feeling ♫
-Okay, I will!
-♫ Streetlights ♫
-Streetlights!
-♫ People ♫
-Streetlights! People!
Streetlights!
People!
-♫ Don´t stop ♫
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫ Don´t stop believin´ ♫
♫ Hold on to that feeling ♫
♫ Streetlights, people ♫
♫ Don´t stop believin´ ♫
-Streetlights! People!
-♫ Hold on to that feeling ♫
♫ Streetlights, people ♫
♫♫
[ Laughing ]
Here´s how the game works.
One person -- one person
puts on these headphones
with very loud music playing.
You can play this at home.
The other person picks up a card
and reads the random phrase
on that card,
and the person wearing
headphones has to try and guess
what the other person said.
Will, you put the headphones
on first.
-Okay.
-I´ll read a phrase to you,
and then you´ll guess
what I´m saying.
Let´s make sure
the music is playing.
Can you hear me?
-Yeah.
-Can you hear me?
-Huh?
Good.
Music´s playing?
-Yep.
-Yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
A beautiful day
in the neighborhood.
-A boot full of...
-A beautiful day --
-A boat full...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-A beautiful day
in the neighborhood.
-A beautiful day in
the neighborhood.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] What?
How did you know that?
Did you peek at my card?
-No. You have
very readable lips.
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, it is...
It´s my turn here.
Let´s see how I do.
-You do it now?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
-I´m sorry.
Oh, yeah.
[ Vocalizing and laughing ]
I like this.
I want to download this.
-You should.
-Okay.
-Yeah?
-Yep, yep, yep, yep.
[ Laughter ]
-I have a shoplifting problem.
-I have...
-I have a serious
shoplifting problem.
Stealing makes me feel big.
[ Laughter ]
-She ate cheddar cheese?
-I steal everything --
groceries, books, cold medicine.
I know I´m sick,
but I can´t help myself.
-Uh...help? Help? Help?
-It´s like a high to me.
I love the danger
of almost getting caught.
-Slow down, slow down,
slow down.
-Can you imagine the headlines?
"Will Ferrell arrested
for shoplifting at Kohl´s."
God, that´d be so humiliating.
-Beer koozie.
-But what can I say?
It turns me on.
-Attorney at law?
I have no clue. I´m sorry.
-No, it was Baby Yoda.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I should have gotten Baby Yoda.
That´s pretty famous.
You were just saying "Baby Yoda"
over and over?
-I go?
-Yeah, you go.
Okay. You put on the headphones.
[ Clears throat ]
-Imp--
-Impossible Whopper.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How?
-It´s a gift.
It´s a gift. Your turn.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, all right,
we´ll do one more round.
-Okay.
-Feeling good about this.
[ Clears throat ]
Okay, let´s do it.
Come on. I can do it.
-Okay.
-I can do it.
-Do you like cults?
I´m starting one,
and guess what?
You´re my first member.
I´ve already seized
your bank accounts
and stolen your identity.
You shouldn´t leave
your e-mail open.
Do you know how easy it is to
find a Social Security number?
I´m going to erase you.
-Shush?
Uh, California Raisins?
-We´ll worship
Jonathan Lipnicki as a god.
We´re going to use your money
to build a temple
dedicated
to the Jonathan Lipnicki movie
"The Little Vampire,"
and your new legal name
will be Jonathan Lopnocki
because it´s as close
as we can get to naming you
after our new god
without angering him.
-Anger management?
-I´m gonna dye your hair blond
and make you wear
little round glasses.
And instead of "hello,"
you´ll greet me by saying,
"Did you know that the human
head weighs eight pounds?"
And then I´ll say, "Really?
Let´s find out for ourselves."
And that´s when I´m gonna pop
your pretty little head off
like a [bleep] dandelion.
All it takes is a dull knife
and 10 minutes.
And that´s when
I take your glasses
and I put them on my own face,
and then I see what God sees.
Then I see what our god,
Jonathan Lipnicki, sees.
-Then I see what our god,
-Nailed it.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
-We got it!
-Right!
-Very good.
-Yeah.
-We´re good at this.
Will Ferrell, everybody!
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♫ Everybody´s talking
about my tight pants ♫
♫ Got my tight pants,
got my tight pants on ♫
♫ Everybody´s looking at
my tight pants ♫
♫ Got my tight pants,
got my tight pants on ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
-♫ Everybody´s talking about
our tight pants ♫
♫ We got our tight pants,
we got our tight pants on ♫
♫ We´re the only couple
wearing tight pants ♫
♫ We got our tight pants,
we got our tight pants on ♫
-♫ We can dance over here,
we can dance over there ♫
♫ We can walk down the street
and everybody stares ♫
♫ At our tight pants,
we´re the only ones ♫
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♫ Everyone in town
loves my tight pants ♫
♫ I got my tight pants,
I got my tight pants on ♫
♫ No one else around me´s
wearing tight pants ♫
♫ I got my tight pants,
I got my tight pants on ♫
-Whoa!
Slow down there, compadre.
You say people are talking
about your tight pants
down at the local penny arcade?
Well, I find that
hard to believe,
because ever since
we moved to this town,
everyone we know´s been
talking about our tight pants.
-Well, that´s funny
because yesterday
I ran into Mayor Wembley,
and he declared my pants
the tightest in all the land.
-Well, we just welcomed
our brand-new baby boy.
-And when we told the news
to Governor Grimball,
he proclaimed, "Hark!
´Tis the true heir
to the tight pants throne!"
-A new baby, you say?
Well, ain´t that a bag of beans?
Especially since you and I
haven´t spoken
since that one magical night we
shared together nine months ago.
[ Audience cheering ]
-Now, you listen to me,
you fat-face cobbnobler...
[ Laughter ]
...I don´t know who you are
or what butt hole
you crawled out of...
[ Laughter ]
...but this is my woman,
and that is our baby.
And every night he gets swaddled
in the tightest of pants.
We are the only ones that get to
wear tight pants in this town.
You drinking my sake, kemosabe?
-Don´t mess with the lioness.
♫ Nants ingonya ♫
-[ Hissing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You sipping my soupé,
Guadalupe?
[ Laughter ]
-Point taken, Kevin Bacon.
I guess I´ll find a new town.
♫♫
-♫ Everybody´s talking about
our tight pants ♫
♫ We got our tight pants,
we got our tight pants on ♫
-This is a traditional drum-off.
[ Laughter ]
-This is a traditional drum-off?
-What´s that?
-Tonight we´re gonna go by
traditional rules.
[ Laughter ]
This is a traditional drum-off.
You each get four solos.
Whoever whacks, smacks, and
slaps the skins the best wins.
So without further ado,
let the drum-off begin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go, Will!
-Ladies first.
-Take notes, Chadwick.
-Whoo!
-Go, Will!
-[ Drumming ]
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that´s how it´s done.
-All right.
[ Drumming ]
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take that, funny man!
-[ Baby voice ] Oh, it looks
like baby learned
how to "pway" the "dwums."
[ Laughter ]
But can baby do this?
[ Drumming ]
♫♫
I just blew my mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You just blew your mind?
-I just blew my mind.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Drumming ]
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. Let´s see what you got.
-You know what?
-What do you got?
What do you got?
-That was cute.
Do you play for
the Lukewarm Chili Peppers?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Plays drum sting ]
-[ Drumming ]
♫♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
Roll the credits!
-Roll the --
-Roll the credits.
Roll the credits.
Stop the show.
-[ Laughs ] Chad...
-Go to commercial.
Might want to go to commercial.
-Chad...
-All right.
-...do you have a response?
-Roll the credits.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Drumming ]
♫♫
[ Audience cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]